Quand le télégraphe est apparu,
il était clair qu'il allait mondialiser
l'industrie de l'information.
À quoi est-ce que ça conduirait ?
Eh bien, évidemment, ça conduirait à la paix mondiale.
La télévision, un média qui nous a permis non seulement d'entendre
mais de voir, littéralement voir, ce qui se passait
ailleurs dans le monde,
à quoi est-ce que ça conduirait ?
La paix mondiale. (Rires)
Le téléphone ?
Vous l'avez deviné : la paix mondiale.
Désolé pour cette fausse prédiction, mais pas de paix mondiale. Pas encore.
Même la presse à imprimer,
était supposée être un outil qui allait faire respecter
l'hégémonie intellectuelle catholique dans toute l'Europe.
Au lieu de ça, on a eu
les 95 thèses de Martin Luther,
la réforme protestante
et la Guerre de trente ans.
Ce que toutes ces prédictions de paix mondiale ont vu juste,
c'est que lorsque tout d'un coup
beaucoup de nouvelles idées sont mises en circulation,
ça transforme la société.
Là où on s'est précisément trompé,
c'est sur ce qui se passe ensuite.
Plus il y a d'idées en circulation,
plus il y a d'idées à contredire pour chacun.
Plus de médias signifie toujours plus de débat.
Voilà ce qui arrive lorsque l'espace des médias se développe.
Et pourtant, quand on revient sur la presse à imprimer,
dans les premières années, nous aimons ce qui est arrivé.
Nous sommes une société en faveur de l'imprimerie.
Alors, comment concilier ces deux choses,
le fait que ça engendre plus de débat,
mais qu'on pense que c'est bien ?
Et la réponse, je pense,
se trouve dans des choses comme ça.
Il s'agit de la couverture
de « Philosophical Transactions »
la première revue scientifique
jamais publiée en anglais
au milieu du 16e siècle.
Elle a été créée par un groupe de gens
qui se nommaient eux-mêmes
« Le Collège Invisible»,
un groupe de philosophes naturels
qui seulement plus tard s'appellerait scientifiques,
et ils voulaient améliorer la façon
dont les philosophes naturels débattaient,
et pour ça, ils devaient faire deux choses :
ils avaient besoin d'ouverture.
Ils avaient besoin de créer
une norme qui disait,
quand vous faites une expérience,
vous devez publier non seulement vos affirmations,
mais aussi votre procédure.
Si vous ne nous dites pas comment vous l'avez faite,
nous ne vous ferons pas confiance.
Mais il leur fallait aussi aller vite.
Ils ont dû rapidement synchroniser
ce que d'autres philosophes naturels savaient.
Sinon, impossible de lancer le bon type de débat.
L'imprimerie était clairement le bon moyen pour ce faire,
mais le livre était le mauvais outil. Il était trop lent.
Alors ils ont inventé la revue scientifique
comme moyen de synchronisation du débat
dans la communauté des spécialistes des sciences naturelles.
La révolution scientifique n'a pas été créée par la presse à imprimer.
Elle a été créée par des scientifiques,
mais elle n'aurait pas pu l'être
s'ils n'avaient pas eu une presse à imprimer.
Et nous, alors ? Et notre génération,
et notre révolution des médias, d'Internet ?
Des prédictions de paix mondiale ? Vérifions. (Rires)
Plus de débat ? On peut mettre une étoile d'or là-dessus. (Rires)
(Rires)
Je veux dire, YouTube est une mine d'or. (Rires)
Un meilleur débat ? C'est la question.
J'étudie les médias sociaux, ce qui signifie,
de prime abord, que j'observe les gens débattre.
Et si je devais choisir un groupe dont je pense qu'il est
notre Collège Invisible, c'est la collection de notre génération de gens
qui essayent de prendre ces outils et de les utiliser,
non pas pour plus d'arguments,
mais pour de meilleurs arguments,
je choisirais les programmeurs opensource.
La programmation est une relation triangulaire
entre un programmeur, un code source,
et l'ordinateur sur lequel
le programme est destiné à être exécuté,
mais les ordinateurs interprètent les instructions
de façon si rigide
qu'il est extraordinairement difficile d'écrire
tout un ensemble d'instructions que l'ordinateur sache exécuter,
et nous parlons du cas où une seule personne l'a écrit.
Quand il y a plus d'une personne
il est très facile pour n'importe lequel deux programmeurs
d'écraser leurs travaux respectifs
s'ils travaillent sur le même fichier,
ou d'envoyer des instructions incompatibles
ce qui fait que l'ordinateur s'étouffe,
et ce problème s'accroît
avec le nombre de programmeurs impliqués.
En gros, le problème de la gestion
d'un grand projet de logiciel
c'est d'éviter ce chaos social.
Depuis des décennies, une solution canonique
à ce problème consiste à utiliser ce qu'on appelle
un « système de contrôle de version »,
qui fait ce qui est marqué sur la boite.
Il fournit une copie canonique du logiciel
sur un serveur quelque part.
Les seuls programmeurs à pouvoir le changer sont des personnes
qui ont reçu spécifiquement l'autorisation d'y accéder,
et ils sont seulement autorisés à accéder à la sous-section
qu'ils sont autorisés à modifier.
Et quand les gens dessinent
des diagrammes de systèmes de contrôle de version,
ils ressemblent toujours à ça.
Ils ressemblent à des organigrammes hiérarchiques.
Et pas besoin de plisser les yeux très fort
pour voir les ramifications politiques d'un tel système.
C'est du féodalisme : un seul propriétaire, beaucoup d'ouvriers.
C'est très bien pour l'industrie des logiciels commerciaux.
C'est Office DE Microsoft. C'est Photoshop D'Adobe .
La société est propriétaire du logiciel.
Les programmeurs vont et viennent.
Mais il y avait un programmeur qui a décidé
que ce n'était pas la façon de travailler.
Il s'agit de Linus Torvalds.
Torvalds est le programmeur open source le plus célèbre,
il a créé Linux, évidemment, et Torvalds a examiné la façon
dont le mouvement open source s'occupe de ce problème.
Les logiciels libres, la promesse au coeur de la licence open source,
est que tout le monde devrait avoir accès à l'intégralité du code source
tout le temps, mais bien sûr, ça crée
la menace même du chaos qu'il faut prévenir
pour faire que ça marche.
La plupart des projets open source se sont pincé le nez
et ont adopté des systèmes de gestion féodale.
Mais Torvalds a dit, « Non, je vais pas faire ça. »
Son point de vue là-dessus a été très clair.
Lorsque vous adoptez un outil, vous adoptez aussi
la philosophie de gestion intégrée dans cet outil,
et il n'allait pas adopter une chose qui ne marchait pas
comme la communauté Linux .
Pour vous donner une idée de l'énormité
d'une telle décision, voici une carte
des dépendances internes au sein de Linux,
au sein du système d'exploitation Linux,
dont des sections du programme
s'appuient sur d'autres sections pour se lancer.
C'est un processus extrêmement complexe.
C'est un programme extrêmement compliqué,
pourtant, pendant des années,
Torvalds l'a fait tourner
non pas avec des outils automatisés,
mais depuis sa boite e-mail.
Les gens lui envoyaient littéralement par mail
les changements sur lesquels ils se mettaient d'accord,
et il les fusionnait à la main.
Et puis, 15 ans après avoir observé Linux et trouvé
comment la communauté fonctionnait,
il a dit, « Je pense que je sais comment écrire
un système de contrôle de version pour les gens libres. »
Il l'a appelé « Git ».
Git est un contrôle de version distribué.
Il a deux grandes différences
par rapport aux systèmes de contrôle de version traditionnels.
La première est qu'il est à la hauteur
de la promesse philosophique de l'open source.
Tous ceux qui travaillent sur un projet
ont accès à toutes les données du code source
tout le temps.
Et quand les gens dessinent
des diagrammes de flux de travail Git,
ils utilisent des dessins qui ressemblent à ça.
Pas besoin de comprendre ce que les cercles,
les cases et les flèches signifient pour voir qu'il s'agit
d'une façon bien plus compliquée de travailler
que les systèmes de contrôle de version ordinaires ne supportent.
Mais c'est aussi ce qui apporte de nouveau le chaos,
et c'est la deuxième grande innovation de Git.
Voici une capture d'écran de GitHub,
le premier service d'hébergement Git,
et chaque fois qu'un programmeur utilise Git
pour faire un changement important,
en créant un nouveau fichier, en modifiant un fichier existant,
en fusionnant deux fichiers, Git crée ce type de signature.
Cette longue chaîne de chiffres et de lettres
est un identificateur unique lié à chaque modification unique,
mais sans coordination centrale.
Chaque système Git génère ce numéro de la même façon,
ce qui signifie que c'est une signature liée directement
et sans possibilité de falsification sur un changement particulier.
Ceci a l'effet suivant :
un programmeur à Édimbourg et un programmeur à Entebbe
peuvent tous les deux avoir une copie du même logiciel.
Chacun d'eux peut apporter des modifications,
et ils peuvent les fusionner ensuite,
même s'ils ne savent pas au préalable
que l'autre existe.
Il s'agit de coopération sans coordination.
Voilà le grand changement.
Je vous dis tout ça non pas pour vous convaincre que c'est génial
que des programmeurs opensource disposent maintenant d'un outil
qui prend en charge leur manière philosophique de travailler,
bien que je pense que c'est très bien.
Je vous dis tout ça à cause de ce que je pense que ça signifie
pour la manière dont les communautés se réunissent.
Une fois que Git a permis la coopération sans coordination,
on commence à voir des communautés se former
qui sont extrêmement vastes et complexes.
Voici un diagramme de la communauté Ruby.
C'est un langage de programmation open source,
et de toutes les interconnexions entre les personnes --
voici maintenant non pas un graphique du logiciel,
mais un graphe de personnes,
toutes les interconnexions entre les personnes
qui travailent sur ce projet :
et ça ne ressemble pas à un organigramme hiérarchique.
Ça ressemble à une organigramme dis-hiérarchique, et pourtant,
à partir de cette communauté, mais à l'aide de ces outils,
ils peuvent désormais créer quelque chose ensemble.
Donc, il y a deux bonnes raisons de penser que
ce genre de technique peut être appliqué
aux démocraties en général et en particulier à la Loi.
Lorsque vous avancez, en fait,
que quelque chose sur Internet va être bon
pour la démocratie,
vous obtenez souvent cette réaction.
(Musique) (Rires)
Qui est, tu parles du truc
avec les chats qui chantent ? C'est le truc
dont vous pensez qu'il va être bon pour la société ?
Et là, je dois dire, voilà ce qu'il y a
avec les chats qui chantent. C'est toujours le cas.
Je ne veux pas seulement dire
que ça se passe toujours comme ça avec internet,
je veux dire que
c'est toujours comme ça
avec les médias, point final.
Il n'a pas fallu longtemps
après la naissance de l'imprimerie commerciale
avant que quelqu'un comprenne
que les romans érotiques étaient une bonne idée.
(Rires)
Pas besoin d'une incitation économique
à vendre des livres
avant que quelqu'un ne dise,
« Hé, vous savez combien j'ai parié
que les gens paieraient pour ça ? »
(Rires)
Il a fallu aux gens encore 150 ans
pour penser à la revue scientifique, pas vrai ?
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
L'exploitation du Collège invisible de l'imprimerie
pour créer la revue scientifique
a été extrêmement important,
mais ça n'a eu que des proportions modestes,
ce n'est pas arrivé vite,
alors si vous allez chercher où les changements se produisent,
il faut regarder vers les marges.
La loi est aussi liée à la dépendance.
Voici un graphique du Code fiscal des États-Unis,
et les dépendances d'une loi aux autres lois
pour l'effet global.
Donc il y a ça comme site pour la gestion du code source.
Mais il y a aussi le fait que le droit
est un autre endroit
où il y a beaucoup d'opinions en circulation,
mais elles ont besoin d'être résolues
en un seul exemplaire canonique,
et quand vous allez voir sur GitHub,
il y a des millions et des millions de projets,
presque tous sont du code source,
mais si vous regardez plus loin,
vous pouvez voir des gens
expérimenter avec les ramifications politiques
d'un tel système
Quelqu'un a mis en ligne tous les câbles de Wikileaks
du département d'État,
ainsi que des logiciels utilisés pour les interpréter,
y compris mon utilisation préférée
des câbles Cablegate, qui est un outil pour détecter
les haïkus qui appariassent naturellement dans la prose
du département d' État.
(Rires)
Bon. (Rires)
Le Sénat de New York a mis en place ce qu'on appelle
la législation ouverte,
et l'héberge aussi sur GitHub,
encore une fois pour toutes les raisons
de mise à jour et de fluidité.
Vous pouvez aller choisir votre sénateur
et ensuite vous pouvez voir
une liste des lois qu'il a parrainées.
Quelqu'un avec le pseudo de Divegeek
a mis en ligne le code de l'Utah,
les lois de l'État de l'Utah,
et il l'a mis là
non seulement pour distribuer le code,
mais avec la possibilité très intéressante
que ça pourrait servir à faire progresser
le développement de la législation.
Quelqu'un a mis en ligne un outil
au cours du débat sur le droit d'auteur
l'an dernier au Sénat, en disant :
« Il est étrange que Hollywood ait plus accès
aux législateurs canadiens que les citoyens canadiens.
Pourquoi n'utilisons-nous pas GitHub
pour leur montrer à quoi peut ressembler
un projet de loi mis au point par les citoyens ? »
Et il inclut cette capture d'écran très évocatrice.
C'est ce qu'on appelle un « diff », ce truc ici à droite.
Ça vous montre, pour du texte que beaucoup de gens éditent,
quand une modification a été effectuée, qui l'a faite,
et quel est le changement.
Les trucs en rouge sont
ceux qui ont été supprimés.
Les trucs en vert sont
ceux qui ont été ajoutés.
Pour les programmeurs ça va de soi.
Aucune démocratie nulle part dans le monde
ne propose cette fonctionnalité à ses citoyens,
ni pour la législation ni pour les budgets,
même si ce sont les choses faites
avec notre consentement et avec notre argent.
Maintenant, j'aimerais vous dire que
le fait que les programmeurs opensource aient mis au point
une méthode collaborative à grande échelle, distribuée,
bon marché et en phase avec les idéaux de la démocratie,
je serais ravi de vous dire que,
parce que ces outils sont en place,
l'innovation est inévitable.
Mais ce n'est pas le cas.
Une partie du problème, bien sûr,
est juste un manque d'information.
Quelqu'un a mis une question sur Quora :
« Comment se fait-il que les législateurs
n'utilisent pas le contrôle de version distribué ? »
Voici la réponse qui a été donnée, graphiquement. (Rires)
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
Et en effet, ça fait partie du problème, mais seulement en partie.
Le plus gros problème, bien sûr, est le pouvoir.
Les gens qui expérimentent avec la participation
n'ont pas le pouvoir législatif et
les gens qui ont le pouvoir législatif
n'expérimentent pas avec la participation.
Ils expérimentent avec l'ouverture.
Il n'y a pas de démocratie digne de ce nom
qui n'ait pas essayé une transparence,
mais la transparence est l'ouverture dans un seul sens
et se voir donner un tableau de bord
sans un volant n'a jamais été la promesse de base
qu'une démocratie fait à ses citoyens.
Alors, pensez-y.
Ce qui a fait que des avis de Martha Payne
sont parvenus au public c'était une technologie,
mais ce qui a fait qu'on a continué à s'y intéresser,
c'était la volonté politique.
C'était l'attente des citoyens
qu'elle ne serait pas censurée.
Voilà où nous sommes avec ces outils de collaboration.
Nous les avons. Nous les avons vus. Ils fonctionnent.
Pouvons-nous les utiliser ?
Peut-on généraliser les techniques qui ont fonctionné ici à ça ?
T.S. Eliot a dit: « Une des choses les plus mémorables
qui puisse arriver à une culture
est qu'on acquière une nouvelle forme de prose.»
Je pense que c'est faux, mais... (Rires)
Je pense que ce n'est valable que pour l'argumentation. Pas vrai ?
Ce qui peut arriver d'important à une culture
est qu'on puisse acquérir un nouveau style d'argumentation :
le procès avec jury, le droit de vote, l'examen par les pairs,
et maintenant ceci. Pas vrai ?
Une nouvelle forme d'argumentation a été inventée de notre vivant,
dans la dernière décennie, en fait.
Elle est géniale, elle est distribuée, elle est peu coûteuse,
et elle est compatible avec les idéaux de la démocratie.
Maintenant, la question pour nous est,
allons-nous laisser les programmeurs
la garder pour eux ?
Ou allons-nous tenter
de la prendre
et de la mettre au service
de la société dans son ensemble ?
Merci de m'avoir écouté.
(Applaudissements)
Merci. Merci. (Applaudissements)